vers 7 heures du matin heure locale des
détonations sont entendues à lviv juste
après le retentissement des sirènes
d'alarmé dans le ciel un nuage de fumée
apparaît selon le maire de la ville des
missiles russes ont touché les alentours
de l'aéroport dans un communiqué l'armée
de l'air ukrainienne affirment qu'ils
ont été tirés depuis la mer noire à
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres du
lieu de l'impact une usine de réparation
d'avions a été détruite un site fermé
depuis plusieurs jours pour l'heure
aucune victime n'est à déplorer
dimanche dernier la région de lviv
située au nord-ouest du pays près de la
pologne et pour la première fois
bombardée par l'armée russe plusieurs
sites militaires sont visés certains
abritant des volontaires étrangers au
total une trentaine de personnes sont
tuées métropole de sept cent mille
habitants vivent s'est transformée en
base arrière humanitaire depuis le début
du conflit elle accueille les aides
matérielles venus d'europe ainsi que les
ukrainiens fuyant vers lost